It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. first reaction when someone cuts you off in traffic? What about when you stubbed your toe or bash your finger with a hammer? If you're like most of us, you probably let out a choice word or two. Swearing is a part of most people's vocabulary, and in recent decades, it's become increasingly acceptable in movies, on television, and in other places where it used to be forbidden. Opinions might vary on whether that's a good thing, but here's a point in favor of profanity. psychologists who study swearing are finding out that using these taboo words may have some unexpected
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。当有人在交通中强行加塞时，你的第一反应是什么？当你踢到脚趾或用锤子砸到手指时呢？如果你和我们大多数人一样，你可能会脱口而出几个“精选”词汇。咒骂是大多数人词汇的一部分，近几十年来，它在电影、电视以及过去被禁止的其他场合中变得越来越被接受。关于这是否是一件好事，人们的看法可能各不相同，但这里有一个支持咒骂的观点：研究咒骂的心理学家发现，使用这些禁忌词汇可能会带来一些意想不到的
benefits for people's mental and physical health. So why do we swear? Can swearing during a stressful or painful moment actually make us feel better? Is it true that swearing is a sign of low intelligence or limited vocabulary? To curse words exist in every language. Do people generally swear more than they used to in everyday life? And if they do, might swearing lose some of its power to heal as well as shock. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Richard Stevens, a senior lecturer in psychology at Keel University in the UK. He studies the psychology of emotion, including how swearing can
对人们身心健康的好处。那么，我们为什么要咒骂？在压力或痛苦时刻咒骂真的能让我们感觉好些吗？咒骂是低智商或词汇量有限的标志，这种说法是真的吗？咒骂词汇是否存在于每一种语言中？人们在日常生活中是否比过去骂得更多了？如果确实如此，咒骂是否会失去它既能治愈又能令人震惊的力量？欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是英国基尔大学心理学高级讲师理查德·史蒂文斯博士。他研究情绪心理学，包括咒骂如何
help people withstand pain and improve strength and physical performance. His book, Black Sheep, The Hidden Benefits of Being Bad, won the 2017 British Psychological Society Book of the Year Award for popular science. Dr. Stevens' research has also been covered by media outlets, including The Washington Post, the New York Times, and The New Yorker. Dr. Stevens, thank you for joining me today. Hello, Kim. Thanks for having me. The fact that there is actual scientific research on swearing may be news to many of our listeners,
帮助人们忍受痛苦并提高力量和身体表现。他的著作《黑羊：变坏的隐藏好处》获得了 2017 年英国心理学会年度科普图书奖。史蒂文斯博士的研究也受到了包括《华盛顿邮报》、《纽约时报》和《纽约客》在内的媒体报道。史蒂文斯博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。你好，金。谢谢你的邀请。对于我们许多听众来说，咒骂领域竟然有实际的科学研究，这可能还是个新闻。
What got you interested in this field of study? Yeah, curiosity, pure and simple curiosity. So things like doing DIY projects at home, and there was one particular incident when I hit my little finger with a hammer really, really hard, and it really, really hurt. And I was on my own, there was no one around, but I remember repeating a swear word for about a minute or two.
是什么让你对这个研究领域感兴趣的？是的，好奇心，纯粹而简单的好奇心。比如在家做 DIY 项目时，有一次我用锤子狠狠地砸到了小指，真的非常非常疼。当时我一个人，周围没有人，但我记得我重复了一个咒骂词大约一两分钟。
Things seemed to get better, and I carried on, you know. and the birth of our daughter as well it was a long labour and the baby was actually breach but hadn't been diagnosed as such and towards the end as the contractions were coming on my wife was in a lot of pain and was swearing quite a bit with the pain
事情似乎好转了，我就继续干活了。还有我们女儿出生的时候，那是一次漫长的分娩，婴儿实际上是臀位，但之前并没有诊断出来。在最后阶段，随着宫缩袭来，我妻子感到非常痛苦，因为疼痛咒骂了不少。
and then when the contractions ease she was a little bit embarrassed at having been doing that with the growing number of medical staff with us and then the contractions would come back and it would repeat and what I remember very clearly was when my wife was saying
然后当宫缩缓解时，她因为在这么多医护人员面前那样做而感到有点尴尬，接着宫缩又回来了，她又重复了。我记得非常清楚的是，当我的妻子在
apologising for the swearing for the swearing. Someone said, a midwife said, don't apologize. We hear this all the time. It's a completely normal part of giving birth. So, oh, swearing and pain go together. The psychologist in me thought, why does that happen? For the purposes of your research, what constitutes swearing, and is it different from cursing? I think they're the same. There's a slight language issue, because we don't really say cursing in the UK, but my understanding is the terms are interchangeable. What I mean by swearing is the examples are given where you stub your toe or, you know, or something else happens.
为咒骂道歉时，有人，一位助产士说，别道歉。我们经常听到这个。这是分娩过程中完全正常的一部分。所以，哦，咒骂和疼痛是联系在一起的。我心中的心理学家在想，为什么会这样？为了你的研究目的，什么构成了咒骂，它和诅咒有什么不同吗？我认为它们是一样的。这有一点语言上的问题，因为我们在英国并不怎么说“诅咒”（cursing），但我的理解是这两个词是可以互换的。我所说的咒骂是指那些当你踢到脚趾或发生其他事情时所给出的例子。
In the studies that we do, we have people repeat a swear word at a steady volume and pace. And that's how we operationalize swearing. Some peer reviewers have questioned whether that is swearing, but I guess it's a form of swearing. And it mirrors certainly how I was behaving when I hit myself with the hammer. So that kind of then catulates what we're talking about. Now, I'm a bit of a word nerd, and I was surprised to learn a new one while prepping for our interview. Lalochia, it means the use of vulgar or foul language to relieve stress or pain. The existence of an actual word seems to indicate that this is a pretty universal practice.
在我们做的研究中，我们让人们以稳定的音量和节奏重复一个咒骂词。这就是我们将咒骂操作化的方式。一些同行评审员质疑这是否算咒骂，但我认为这是一种咒骂形式。它确实反映了我砸到自己手指时的行为。所以这概括了我们正在讨论的内容。现在，我有点文字控，在准备采访时学到一个新词让我感到惊讶。Lalochia，意思是使用粗俗或下流的语言来缓解压力或疼痛。这个词的存在似乎表明这是一种相当普遍的做法。
Is that true? Yeah, I think it is. I mean, it's an interesting story with the word, because the word existed before this swearing and pain research is coming out. out, but it was the use of a swear word to relieve stress was the extent of the definition. And you found this word in kind of medical sort of dictionaries. But it has been extended since our research came out to include stress and pain. I think any language that has swearing, probably people will very quickly think it's a good idea to swear when you're in pain. One of the things I've always said is, you know, the research that I've done, it's sort of
是真的吗？是的，我认为是。我的意思是，关于这个词的故事很有趣，因为在咒骂和疼痛的研究出来之前，这个词就已经存在了。但它的定义仅限于使用咒骂词来缓解压力。你在某种医学词典中发现了这个词。但自从我们的研究发表以来，它的定义已经扩展到包括压力和疼痛。我认为任何有咒骂词汇的语言，人们可能很快就会想到在痛苦时咒骂是个好主意。我一直说的一件事是，你知道，我所做的研究，在某种程度上它是在
confirming what everybody already knows in a way, but at least it is confirming that that swearing has some benefit, and then we're trying to uncover how psychologically, what's the mechanism for that. You've done research into the benefits, so can you tell the listeners, what have you found? I mean, what's good about swearing? Yeah, so we started off with this very applied question of, you know, why do people swear when they're in pain? Does swearing help people when they're in pain? and to research that, it's kind of lab-based research. We need to introduce a pain stimulus that's painful but not harmful. And I've exclusively used ice-cold water in the studies that I've run
证实每个人都已经知道的事情，但至少它证实了咒骂确实有一些好处，然后我们正在尝试揭示心理上它是如何运作的，即其机制是什么。你对这些好处进行了研究，你能告诉听众，你发现了什么吗？我的意思是，咒骂有什么好处？是的，所以我们从一个非常应用的问题开始，即为什么人们在痛苦时会咒骂？咒骂能帮助痛苦中的人吗？为了研究这一点，这是一种基于实验室的研究。我们需要引入一种痛苦但无害的疼痛刺激。在我的研究中，我专门使用了冰水。
because that's quite a nice, cheap way to operationalise that. Putting your hand in ice-cold water, provides you don't have certain underlying medical conditions, is painful but not harmful. So we've had people basically put their hand in ice-cold water, holds it there for as long as they can and repeat either a swear word of their choice or a neutral word,
因为这是一种操作化该过程的既好又便宜的方法。将手放入冰水中，只要你没有某些潜在的医疗状况，就是痛苦但无害的。所以我们基本上让人们把手放进冰水里，尽可能长时间地保持在那里，并重复一个他们选择的咒骂词或一个中性词，
which we've tended to use a word to describe a table, which is something my students came up with years ago. And we have a behavioural measure of pain tolerance, which is how long does the hand stay in the water for, keep your hand in the water for as long as you can, basically. And across quite a number of studies now, we've shown that people will keep their in the water longer when they're repeating a swear word.
我们倾向于使用一个描述桌子的词，这是我学生几年前想出来的。我们有一个衡量疼痛耐受力的行为指标，那就是手在水里能待多久，基本上就是让你尽可能长时间地把手放在水里。在目前相当多的研究中，我们已经证明，当人们重复一个咒骂词时，他们会在水里坚持得更久。
What if they yell a word like fudge, right, which is close to the Fudge, but not actually it? Does that have any effect? Yeah, we've got some unpublished data. I really need to get on and publish this study, but you get an intermediate effect for a kind of intermediate swear word, which I guess you might expect, because what we presume is happening is if someone says fudge, they are to somewhat, they're somewhat, you know, activating schema linked to swearing, but not as fully as if they, you know, said the full word. And so they get partial benefit from it. It sort of leads me to theorising about how, how swearing might work. It's, it's almost like, I think swearing is a
如果他们大喊像“fudge”（软糖）这样的词，这很接近那个词，但实际上并不是，那会有什么效果吗？是的，我们有一些未发表的数据。我真的需要抓紧时间发表这项研究，但对于那种中间程度的咒骂词，你会得到一个中间效果，我想你可能也会预料到这一点，因为我们推测发生的情况是，如果有人说“fudge”，他们是在某种程度上激活了与咒骂相关的图式，但没有像说出完整词汇那样充分。所以他们从中获得了部分好处。这让我开始推测咒骂是如何运作的。它几乎就像，我认为咒骂是
double taboo, actually. So a swear word is taboo in so much as the sentiment behind the word, the semantics of the word are taboo. The kind of things that we have swear words for are usually taboo to do with sex or bodily functions and so on. But also the word itself is taboo as well. The swear words themselves divorce from their meaning, I think, carry additional taboo. So it's almost like with a partial swear word or a mild swear word, you're activating part of that double taboo, but not all of it. So I really need to get on and do that study properly and get that out there, but that's a work in progress. You've also looked at how swearing affects strength. What have you found in your research? The story behind that was with the swearing and pain stuff, we were
双重禁忌。所以一个咒骂词之所以是禁忌，是因为词背后的情感，词的语义是禁忌的。我们有咒骂词的那些事物通常是关于性或身体功能等方面的禁忌。但词本身也是禁忌。我认为脱离了意义的咒骂词本身带有额外的禁忌。所以这几乎就像使用部分咒骂词或温和的咒骂词，你激活了那双重禁忌的一部分，但不是全部。所以我真的需要抓紧时间把那项研究做好并发表出来，但这还在进行中。你也研究了咒骂如何影响力量。你在研究中发现了什么？背后的故事是，随着咒骂和疼痛的研究，我们
finding that as well as swearing helping you keep your hands in the ice cold water for longer, there was a accompanying psychophysiological effects of increased heart rate. all of which is consistent with the sort of emotional aspect of swearing, bringing about a certain degree of activation of autonomic nervous system activity or the fight or flight response. And the obvious question then, well, is if swearing activates the fight or flight response, swearing should make you stronger because, you know, fight or flight adrenaline and all that sort of thing. So that was the starting point. So we've run a couple of studies now, maybe three or four actually, where we've looked at swearing and physical performance.
发现咒骂不仅能帮助你把手在冰水里放得更久，还伴随着心率加快的心理生理效应。所有这些都与咒骂的情绪方面一致，即引起了自主神经系统活动或“战斗或逃跑”反应的一定程度的激活。那么显而易见的问题是，如果咒骂激活了“战斗或逃跑”反应，咒骂应该让你变得更强，因为你知道，战斗或逃跑、肾上腺素等等。所以这就是起点。所以我们现在已经进行了几项研究，实际上可能是三四项，我们研究了咒骂和身体表现。
The puzzling thing with those studies is we've shown that swearing benefits physical task performance. We've had people on kind of an exercise bike task where they have to cycle for 30 seconds on a stationary bike against a very large load. It's called the windgate test. And people perform that with greater power when they're repeating a swing. swear word compared to the neutral word. We've also shown for kind of a hand grip task, which is like a, it's called a hand grip dynamometer, and it's like a little handheld device.
这些研究令人困惑的地方在于，我们已经证明咒骂有利于身体任务的表现。我们让人们在一种健身车任务上，他们必须在固定自行车上以很大的负荷骑行 30 秒。这被称为温盖特测试（Wingate test）。与中性词相比，当人们重复一个咒骂词时，他们以更大的力量完成了任务。我们还展示了对于一种握力任务，这被称为握力计，它像一个小手持设备。
The stronger you grip it, the more a little needle goes round on a dial. People will grip that more strongly, repeating a swear word than a neutral word. And then when COVID came along and we had to pivot to online, we had people doing a chair push-up, which is basically I'll do it now while I'm talking. You put your hands underneath your thighs
你握得越紧，表盘上的小针转得越多。与中性词相比，人们在重复咒骂词时会握得更紧。然后当新冠疫情来临时，我们不得不转向在线研究，我们让人们做椅子俯卧撑，这基本上是我现在说话时要做的。你把手放在大腿下面，
and then you lift your body weight up and feet off the floor and support your body weight on your arms so I'm doing now and hold that position for as long as you can and all three of those tasks we've shown that people will perform those tasks either with greatest strength
然后你把身体抬起来，脚离开地面，用手臂支撑体重，就像我现在做的那样，并尽可能长时间地保持这个姿势。在这三项任务中，我们都证明了当人们重复一个咒骂词时，他们会以更大的力量
or for longer when they're repeating a swear word but puzzlingly in the lab-based studies we didn't see the psychophysiological reaction that we predicted would be the cause of that effect so we found the effect but for some other cause which has actually been quite interesting because that senses down the path of exploring more psychological mechanisms rather than psychophysiological mechanisms to explain how it all works. Does it matter which swear word a person uses are some more potent than others?
或坚持更长的时间来完成这些任务。但令人困惑的是，在实验室研究中，我们没有看到我们预测会成为该效应原因的心理生理反应。所以我们发现了这种效应，但它是由于其他原因，这实际上非常有趣，因为它引导我们走上了探索更多心理机制而不是心理生理机制的道路，来解释这一切是如何运作的。一个人使用哪个咒骂词重要吗？有些词比其他词更有效吗？
More than likely, yes, but limited research findings to back that up. You asked me earlier about Fudge, and we've done research with kind of mild swear words compared with stronger swear words. to see a dose effect response. And the data suggests so, but we've never got those published. So that's not out there in the peer review world. So we can't make too much claim on that. But we mostly say to people, choose your own swear word, and the variety is interesting that comes back with that.
很有可能，是的，但支持这一点的研究发现有限。你刚才问我关于“Fudge”的问题，我们已经用温和的咒骂词与更强烈的咒骂词进行了研究，以观察剂量效应反应。数据表明确实如此，但我们从未发表过这些结果。所以这在同行评审的世界里还没有公开。所以我们不能对此做出太多声明。但我们通常告诉人们，选择你自己的咒骂词，反馈回来的多样性很有趣。
Because it probably is personal. One person's kind of strong swear word is, you know, it's a personal history that we have with these words. However, when we have run studies where we've said, you know, use the F word, that seems. to work pretty well and probably the majority of people choose that word anyway. What about hand gestures, flipping the bird? Does that have the same effect as saying the word that it represents out loud? I ran a study a few years ago where we looked at people doing the
因为它可能确实是个人的。一个人的强烈咒骂词，你知道，是我们与这些词的个人历史。然而，当我们进行研究并说“使用 F 开头的词”时，这似乎效果很好，而且可能大多数人无论如何都会选择那个词。那么手势呢，比如竖中指？这和说出它所代表的词有同样的效果吗？几年前我做了一项研究，我们观察人们做
middle finger gesture rather than saying a swear word. And that showed inconclusive bills. This was a pain study and that study showed inconclusive results. So there was no clear benefit of a sign like that rather than a swear word. Now, I think some more research has come out since, but I'm afraid I'm not across that, so I'm not sure exactly what the situation is with what we know about hand gestures. There's a quote about swearing,
竖中指的手势而不是说咒骂词。结果显示不确定。这是一项疼痛研究，该研究显示结果不确定。所以像这样的手势并没有比咒骂词有明显的益处。现在，我想自从那以后又有了更多的研究，但我恐怕没有关注到，所以我不太确定我们对手势的了解情况到底如何。有一句关于咒骂的名言，
perhaps being the foundation of civilization because it enabled a form of non-physical violence to be inflicted that maybe serves some kind of purpose without escalating things too much. Do you have to say the words out loud, or can you just think of that? them really hard to yourself. Does that make a difference? Again, probably yes. It probably does make a difference. But we have not done studies where we have people thinking the words. So we haven't got like
也许它是文明的基础，因为它使一种非身体暴力得以实施，可能在不使事情升级太多的情况下起到某种作用。你必须大声说出这些词吗，还是你可以在心里对自己狠狠地想它们？这会有什么不同吗？同样，可能是的。这可能确实会有所不同。但我们还没有进行让人们在心里想这些词的研究。所以我们没有像
a definitive research answer for that. One of the issues with getting people to think things is we we're not completely sure if they're definitely doing what we ask. I suspect thinking would have a similar effect, but a milder one. But that's useful, isn't it? Because that means in certain situations, where to say a swear word might not be a great idea, we can think a swear word that's free and it might help. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199.
那样确定的研究答案。让人们思考事物的问题之一是，我们不能完全确定他们是否真的在做我们要求的事情。我怀疑思考会有类似的效果，但会更温和。但这很有用，不是吗？因为这意味着在某些情况下，说出咒骂词可能不是个好主意，我们可以想一个免费的咒骂词，它可能会有帮助。你的夏天从现在开始，家得宝（Home Depot）有阵亡将士纪念日的优惠。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烧烤炉开启夏季户外烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。
And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at, Home Depot. While supplies last, price in valid May 14th May 27th.
整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证的低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。
U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found
仅限美国，有例外情况。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到
the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water.
那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. What's happening physiologically when somebody swears and their pain tolerance increases or their strength increases? What is going on in the body and in the brain? There is evidence out there that the emotional aspect of swearing elicits to psychophysiological response,
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时，你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。当有人咒骂并且他们的疼痛耐受力增加或力量增加时，生理上发生了什么？身体和大脑中发生了什么？有证据表明，咒骂的情绪方面引发了心理生理反应，
basically an autonomic nervous system response and to what we call the fight or flight response. response. And not just in my lab, other labs have shown things like skin conductance, which is how much sweat you have on your skin correlates with how activated our autonomic nervous system or our fight or flight response is. And previous studies have shown that skin conductance is raised with swearing linked to the emotional aspect of it. So part of it is autonomic arousal. But like I say, We've also more recently shown swearing effects in the absence of that. So there are other interesting things happening in the brain, I think, besides the autonomic arousal. Are there other potential benefits of swearing?
基本上是自主神经系统反应，也就是我们所说的“战斗或逃跑”反应。不仅在我的实验室，其他实验室也展示了诸如皮肤电导之类的东西，即你皮肤上的汗水含量与我们的自主神经系统或“战斗或逃跑”反应的激活程度相关。之前的研究表明，皮肤电导随着与咒骂情绪方面相关的咒骂而升高。所以部分原因是自主神经唤醒。但正如我所说，我们最近也证明了在没有这种反应的情况下咒骂的效果。所以我认为大脑中除了自主神经唤醒之外，还有其他有趣的事情在发生。咒骂还有其他潜在的好处吗？
Are there other areas you're looking into, perhaps? What we're looking at the moment is trying to understand the psychology behind the sort of benefits that we've seen so far, like the benefit for pain and the benefit for physical activity. and exploring more into psychological domain and that's very much where the effort is now and where we're moving towards is something to do with swearing seems to make us disinhibited
你还在研究其他领域吗，也许？我们目前正在研究的是试图理解我们迄今为止所看到的那些好处背后的心理学，比如对疼痛的好处和对身体活动的好处，并更多地探索心理领域，这确实是我们现在的努力方向，也是我们正在迈向的方向，这与咒骂似乎使我们去抑制化有关，
seems to be a way of overthrowing societal constraints temporarily so recent studies have shown bits of evidence here and there that are supporting this state of disinhibition hypothesis for swearing And that's a bit like alcohol. That's alcohol makes us disinhibited. So any situation where being disinhibited can be advantageous, I think theoretically, swearing might be able to help us.
似乎是一种暂时推翻社会约束的方法。所以最近的研究显示了一些零星的证据，支持这种咒骂的“去抑制状态”假说。这有点像酒精。酒精使我们去抑制化。所以任何去抑制化可能是有利的场合，我认为理论上，咒骂可能能够帮助我们。
So for example, public speaking, that's kind of a moment when we can feel very inhibited and socially evaluated. Some kind of swearing-woman routine might very well help with that. I think there's really something to this idea of disinhibition. So, for example, years and years ago, there used to be a television show in the UK called Top of the Pops, which was recorded once a week, and all of the latest short topping acts would be performing in the studio in front of a live audience. And I was lucky enough to get tickets for that years and years ago.
例如，公开演讲，那是一种我们可能会感到非常受抑制和被社会评价的时刻。某种咒骂的例行程序很可能对此有帮助。我认为这种去抑制的想法确实有其道理。例如，多年前，英国有一个电视节目叫《Top of the Pops》，每周录制一次，所有最新的热门表演者都会在演播室里在现场观众面前表演。多年前我有幸得到了那张票。
And when you turn up, as the audience, there's a warm-up guy, right? And so you turn up and the warm-up guy is, okay, everybody, how are you? you're doing tonight and everyone goes, oh, okay. And then they go, no, that's not loud enough. How are you doing tonight? And after about 10 minutes, you've transformed, right, to how are you doing? Yeah, I'm fantastic. I'm having amazing time. So there is, I think there's something about inhibition and disinhibition that's quite powerful in terms of our psychology. And I think the evidence that I'm gathering, I think is supporting the idea that swearing can push us to being in a more disinhibited state. And I think that can have benefits, the benefits we've shown so far,
当你到达时，作为观众，有一个暖场的人，对吧？所以你到了，暖场的人说，好吧，大家，你们今晚怎么样？每个人都说，哦，还可以。然后他们说，不，不够大声。你们今晚怎么样？大约 10 分钟后，你就变了，对吧，变成“你们怎么样？是的，我太棒了。我玩得很开心。”所以，我认为在我们的心理学方面，关于抑制和去抑制有一些非常强大的东西。而且我认为我正在收集的证据支持了咒骂可以推动我们进入一种更去抑制状态的想法。而且我认为这可以带来好处，我们迄今为止展示的好处，
but perhaps other ones as well. I'm wondering how swearing relates to other parts of language. Does our brain process profanity in the same way? I mean, I've read that profanity exists in a very specific part of the brain. Is there any truth to that? I think there is, I think swearing is a form of language that is handled differently by the brain. I mean, going back, if you read Stephen Pinker's book, Stuff of Thought, has a really nice chapter on swearing that talks about this stuff in quite an interesting way. So there is evidence that swearing in some ways can be kind of stereotypical language, almost like song lyrics that we might have learned, or poetry might have learned,
但也许还有其他好处。我想知道咒骂与其他语言部分有何关系。我们的大脑处理亵渎语言的方式相同吗？我的意思是，我读到亵渎语言存在于大脑的一个非常特定的部分。这有什么真实性吗？我认为有，我认为咒骂是一种大脑处理方式不同的语言形式。我的意思是，回顾一下，如果你读斯蒂芬·平克的书《思想的材料》（Stuff of Thought），里面有一个关于咒骂的非常好的章节，以一种相当有趣的方式讨论了这些东西。所以有证据表明，咒骂在某些方面可能是一种刻板的语言，几乎就像我们可能学过的歌词，或者可能学过的诗歌，
or if you're in it just prayers that you might know and be able to recite. And there is various evidence from sort of neuropsychological case studies. with brain damage that while the regular brain language areas in the left hemisphere, like Broca's area, Vernica's area, so-called these sort of left cortical brain areas that are heavily involved with language usually, they can be damaged and language can, a person can have difficulties with language and yet still be able to swear fluently, which suggests that language, that it's organized differently in the brain. You've also got people with Tourette's.
或者如果你身处其中，只是你可能知道并能够背诵的祈祷文。并且有来自神经心理学案例研究的各种证据。大脑受损，虽然左半球的常规大脑语言区域，如布罗卡区（Broca's area）、韦尼克区（Wernicke's area），即通常与语言密切相关的所谓左侧皮层大脑区域，它们可能受损，语言可能会出现困难，一个人可能会有语言障碍，但仍然能够流利地咒骂，这表明语言在大脑中的组织方式不同。你还有患有妥瑞氏症（Tourette's）的人。
Only around 50% of people with Tourette's have coprolalia, which is the swearing tick that is so well known. But there is evidence that people with Tourette's have reduced brain volumes of a region called the basal ganglia, which again are well away from the usual language areas, and yet it has this effect on language via that illness. So yeah, there's a few bits of evidence around swearing being a different form of language and handled differently, which you guessed as a psychologist makes it interesting to study. For bilingual people, the swearing in a second language have the same effects as swearing in their first language.
只有大约 50% 的妥瑞氏症患者有秽语症（coprolalia），这是众所周知的咒骂抽动。但有证据表明，妥瑞氏症患者大脑中一个叫基底神经节（basal ganglia）的区域体积减小，这同样远离通常的语言区域，但它通过那种疾病对语言产生了这种影响。所以是的，有一些关于咒骂是一种不同语言形式并被不同处理的证据，作为心理学家，你猜这使得它很有趣去研究。对于双语者来说，用第二语言咒骂和用第一语言咒骂有同样的效果吗？
Depends. Okay. If you become very, very fluent in a second language, then the answer is yes. But for people who have, kind of learned a second language relatively recently, the evidence is that swearing is processed very differently in that second language. So we still don't know, we call it the power of swearing. We still don't really properly know where the power of swearing comes from. It's something to do with learning that there are these taboo words as you're growing up, seeing them deployed in certain situations, perhaps emotionally charged situations. There's something about our relationship with swearing as we grow up.
视情况而定。好的。如果你在第二语言中变得非常非常流利，那么答案是肯定的。但对于那些相对较近才学习第二语言的人来说，证据表明咒骂在第二语言中的处理方式非常不同。所以我们仍然不知道，我们称之为咒骂的力量。我们仍然不知道咒骂的力量来自哪里。这与你在成长过程中学习到有这些禁忌词有关，看到它们在某些情况下被部署，也许是情绪激动的场合。我们成长过程中与咒骂的关系中有些东西，
that gives the words their power. And obviously you don't get that usually with a second language because with a second language, I think quite often it's the first words people learn in a second language because it's kind of fun, isn't it, to find out what the swear words are.
赋予了这些词力量。显然，你通常不会在第二语言中得到那种东西，因为对于第二语言，我认为通常这是人们在第二语言中学习的第一批词，因为这很有趣，不是吗，去找出咒骂词是什么。
But you say, okay, that's a swear word. I'll have to remember that. That's completely different to the way swear words you've grown up with are almost, you know, the association with emotion is so much stronger. So yeah, so we quite often have, in the UK, I'm a big football soccer fan, and we have lots of players from Europe and beyond,
但你说，好的，那是一个咒骂词。我得记住它。这和你从小长大的咒骂词完全不同，几乎，你知道，与情感的联系要强烈得多。所以是的，我们在英国经常有，我是足球迷，我们有很多来自欧洲及其他地区的球员，
who, for whom English is a second language, and frequently they will drop a swear word into a televised interview, because for them it's just a word they've learned and that they use, you know, regularly doesn't have that same gravitas. Which brings me to this idea, which is that swearing seems to be more permissible in places than it used to be, and probably more prevalent in people's everyday language. I mean, I've certainly noticed that in my lifetime. As swearing becomes more common, does it lose its power? We have done some research in my lab that speaks to that,
对他们来说英语是第二语言，他们经常会在电视采访中蹦出一个咒骂词，因为对他们来说，这只是他们学过并经常使用的词，没有那种同样的庄重感。这让我想到了这个想法，即咒骂在某些地方似乎比过去更被允许，而且在人们的日常语言中可能更普遍。我的意思是，在我的一生中我肯定注意到了这一点。随着咒骂变得越来越普遍，它会失去力量吗？我的实验室进行了一些研究，探讨了这一点，
and others have as well that replicates to similar effects. So basically, we ran a version of the swearing of pain study where we asked people additionally, how often do you swear in everyday life? and we managed to kind of get an estimate of daily number of swearwear. So obviously it's going to be a pretty rough estimate. It's a very hard thing to put a number on when asked, but presumably there's some bearing with reality.
其他人也进行了类似的研究，复制了类似的效果。所以基本上，我们进行了咒骂和疼痛研究的一个版本，我们额外询问人们，你在日常生活中多久咒骂一次？我们设法得到了一个日常咒骂次数的估计。所以显然这是一个非常粗略的估计。当被问及时，这是一个很难量化的事情，但推测它与现实有一定的关联。
Anyway, we found that people who swore more often in everyday life got much less benefit of swearing in one of our swearing and pain studies compared with people that swore less often in everyday life. And that kind of makes sense because we know that people habituate to stimuli, if you like, and, you know, it's a fairly fundamental idea in psychology and perception and attention. We have a limited attention system, so we can't attend to absolutely everything that's happening at once. So we quickly habituate to the things that aren't really changing and aren't so important right now, and we concentrate on where things are happening. Why I often say at this point
无论如何，我们发现与在日常生活中咒骂较少的人相比，在日常生活中咒骂较多的人从我们的咒骂和疼痛研究中获得的咒骂益处要少得多。这在某种程度上是有道理的，因为我们知道人们会对刺激产生习惯化，如果你愿意的话，而且，你知道，这是心理学、感知和注意力中一个相当基本的概念。我们有一个有限的注意力系统，所以我们不能同时关注正在发生的一切。所以我们很快就会对那些并不真正改变且目前不那么重要的事情产生习惯化，而我们专注于事情正在发生的地方。我经常在这一点上说
is, I'm sitting down on a chair. If I think about it, I can feel my body, on the chair, whereas a minute ago I wasn't thinking about that at all because I was concentrating on the conversation. That's an example of habituation. I'd habituated to that aspect of where my body is in space and what it's touching. So we've shown in my research that people get a lesser benefit from swearing if they swear more often. And that presumably would happen across the board. If swearing is a more frequently encountered phenomenon for everybody, then it's less of a big deal and it's not going to have the same effect, which suggests that, you know, I agree that swearing does seem to be more prevalent and you see the printed swear words
我正坐在椅子上。如果我思考它，我可以感觉到我的身体在椅子上，而一分钟前我根本没有想过那个，因为我正专注于谈话。这就是习惯化的一个例子。我已经习惯了我的身体在空间中的位置以及它正在接触的东西。所以我的研究表明，如果人们更频繁地咒骂，他们从咒骂中获得的益处就会减少。而这推测会在各个方面发生。如果咒骂对每个人来说都是一种更频繁遇到的现象，那么它就不是什么大不了的事情，也不会产生同样的效果，这表明，你知道，我同意咒骂似乎确实更普遍，你现在在报纸上看到了印刷的咒骂词，
in the newspapers now that you probably didn't 20 years ago. Even the fact we're having this conversation. In fact, you know, I started this research around about 2007 and nobody was researching swearing then because, you know, it was still, it was just stopping, it was just becoming an acceptable level of taboo that that could happen. Now we have networks of swearing researchers. I was looking up to be in Helsinki in January at a swearing research conference, you know, with academics from all over who are interested. So times do change. But yes, you would predict that the more often we come across swearing then it's going to have lesser than effect. But we'd also predict that language evolves. And if the current swear words
而 20 年前你可能看不到。甚至我们正在进行这次谈话的事实。事实上，你知道，我大约在 2007 年开始这项研究，当时没有人研究咒骂，因为，你知道，它仍然是，它只是刚刚停止，它只是刚刚成为一种可以发生的、可接受的禁忌水平。现在我们有了咒骂研究人员的网络。我一月份在赫尔辛基参加了一个咒骂研究会议，你知道，有来自各地的对这感兴趣的学者。所以时代确实在变。但是是的，你会预测我们遇到咒骂的次数越多，它的效果就会越小。但我们也会预测语言会进化。如果当前的咒骂词
were becoming more comfortable with them, presumably some other type of swear word is going to evolve to fulfill this function that swear words were invented to fulfill. Some people say that using a lot of profanity is a sign of low intelligence or at least limited vocabulary. Is that true or is that just a stereotype?
我们对它们变得更适应了，推测某种其他类型的咒骂词将会进化出来，以实现咒骂词被发明出来要实现的这种功能。有些人说使用大量的亵渎语言是低智商或至少是词汇量有限的标志。这是真的，还是仅仅是一个刻板印象？
I think it's more or less a stereotype, but there is a grain of truth in it. We've all come across people who swear every year, second or third word, you know, in what they say, and it's not particularly creative or not particularly adding much to the meaning that's being communicated. So there's a guy Timothy Jay has been researching, persuaring, longer than I have. He's based in Massachusetts College of Liberal Arts. And he came up with this really fantastic scale or measuring device called the swearing
我认为这或多或少是一个刻板印象，但其中有一点真实性。我们都遇到过每隔一两个词就咒骂的人，你知道，在他们所说的话中，它并不是特别有创造力，也不是特别增加了所传达的意义。所以有一个叫蒂莫西·杰伊（Timothy Jay）的人，他研究咒骂的时间比我长。他在马萨诸塞州文理学院工作。他提出了这个非常棒的量表或测量装置，叫做咒骂
fluency task. Okay. So they're already a consist, word fluency tasks that are used routinely by neuropsychologists, and it'll be something like, how many words can you think of in one minute, beginning with the letter A, and a participant has to think of as many words as they can, different words being a letter right. Anyway, Timothy J came up with the swearing version of that task, how many swear words can you think of in one minute, okay? Timothy ran a study whereby participants completed both the standard version of the task, so we got an idea of their verbal fluency, which correlates with IQ, by the way, a high verbal fluency correlates with a high IQ, with their swearing verbal fluency, and guess what?
流利度任务。好的。所以已经存在神经心理学家常规使用的词汇流利度任务，它会是这样的，你在一分钟内能想到多少个以字母 A 开头的词，参与者必须尽可能多地想出不同的词。无论如何，蒂莫西·杰伊提出了该任务的咒骂版本，你在一分钟内能想到多少个咒骂词，好的？蒂莫西进行了一项研究，参与者完成了该任务的标准版本，所以我们了解了他们的语言流利度，顺便说一下，高语言流利度与高智商相关，以及他们的咒骂语言流利度，你猜怎么着？
Positive correlation. People with the highest vocabulary generally have a higher vocabulary of swear words. So it's kind of nuanced, but it's swearing, so swearing in and of itself is not a sign of low IQ and inarticulateness. What is the connection, if any, between swearing? swearing and honesty. I think that's also something you've looked at. Yeah, I've not researched this personally, but I've talked about it occasionally, and I've read some of the studies. So there's basically an idea out there that, I mean, you're probably your guts as someone swearing
正相关。词汇量最大的人通常拥有更多的咒骂词汇量。所以这有点微妙，但咒骂本身并不是低智商和表达能力差的标志。咒骂与诚实之间有什么联系吗？我想这也是你研究过的东西。是的，我没有亲自研究过这个，但我偶尔谈论过它，我也读过一些研究。所以基本上有一种观点认为，我的意思是，你可能对咒骂的人的第一反应是
dishonest because swearing is bad and, you know, bad is associated with dishonesty and so on. So that might be your gut reaction. Whereas if you take a second appraisal, a person who's swearing are they not giving you the unfiltered, this is me, honest version of things? So it goes two ways. So there is some research out there linking, swearing frequency with honesty. And basically they showed that people who swear more frequently scored higher on some kind of honesty rating. So yeah, quite interesting.
不诚实，因为咒骂是不好的，而且，你知道，坏与不诚实相关等等。所以那可能是你的直觉反应。而如果你进行第二次评估，咒骂的人是否没有给你未经过滤的、这就是我、诚实版本的说法？所以它有两个方面。所以有一些研究将咒骂频率与诚实联系起来。基本上他们表明，咒骂更频繁的人在某种诚实评级上得分更高。所以是的，非常有趣。
Well, of course, in court they always make you swear to tell the truth, the whole truth, and nothing but the truth. got to be some connection between honesty and swearing. I mean, I think there is a connection there because the expression swearing comes from to swear an oath, and it would have been to swear an oath on God or a religious oath originally. And of course, that's exactly what a person swearing in and court is doing. So just to wrap up, what are the big questions that you're still trying to answer? Yeah, so this link between swearing and state disinhibition is one of the big questions. I think there's a strong case that this is an important mechanism in how swearing
嗯，当然，在法庭上他们总是让你发誓说实话，全部真相，除了真相什么都没有。这之间一定有某种联系，诚实和咒骂。我的意思是，我认为那里有联系，因为“发誓”（swearing）这个表达来自“发誓”（to swear an oath），它最初是对上帝发誓或宗教誓言。当然，这正是法庭上发誓的人正在做的事情。所以最后，你还在试图回答哪些大问题？是的，所以咒骂与状态去抑制之间的这种联系是最大的问题之一。我认为有强有力的理由认为这是咒骂如何
confers the benefits that it does. We were really excited to run an EEG study last year that came out this January and we measured an EEG is like brain electrical activity. And from studies with alcohol, there's an EEG signal linked to disinhibition that we know from researching alcohol. It's called error-related negativity. And basically, when you're doing a task, if you make a mistake, it's almost like a, ah, damn, made a mistake. It's like this kind of response that we have, this neural response. And our prediction was that we should see a reduced error-related negativity signal in EEG in a swearing condition compared to a neutral word condition, because that's linked to state disinhibition.
带来它所带来的好处的一个重要机制。我们非常兴奋去年进行了一项脑电图（EEG）研究，该研究于今年一月发表，我们测量了脑电图，就像大脑电活动一样。从酒精的研究中，有一个与去抑制相关的脑电图信号，我们从酒精研究中知道。它被称为错误相关负波（error-related negativity）。基本上，当你执行一项任务时，如果你犯了一个错误，它几乎就像一个，“啊，该死，犯了个错误。”这就像我们拥有的这种反应，这种神经反应。我们的预测是，与中性词条件相比，我们在咒骂条件下应该会看到脑电图中错误相关负波信号的减少，因为这与状态去抑制有关。
We ran the study and we didn't find the predicted effects. That's science. The study was published in January in the course we journal of experimental psychology if anyone was interested in looking it up. We did show some self-report measures linked to state distribution that hadn't been used before, showed a relationship to swearing, showed an effect with swearing. So like I say, partially found that. So it would be nice to do some more EEG work, perhaps look at some different signals
我们进行了这项研究，但没有发现预测的效果。这就是科学。这项研究于一月份发表在《实验心理学杂志》上，如果有人有兴趣查阅的话。我们确实展示了一些与状态去抑制相关的自我报告测量，这些测量以前没有被使用过，显示了与咒骂的关系，显示了咒骂的效果。所以正如我所说，部分发现了这一点。所以如果能做更多的脑电图工作会很好，也许看看一些不同的信号，
but I think the state disinhibition work is really interesting and potentially really useful. Another strand of work is looking at, like this question of where does the power of swearing come from? We've done a bit of work collecting people's personal history of swearing, like recollections of swearing and trying to analyze those. So, you know, we can talk about the soap and water hypothesis for where swearing gets its power from, the idea that as a child you swear and adults admonishes you for swearing, perhaps going as far as washing your mouth out with soap and water, and, you know, the trauma of that, the shame of that or whatever is in view swearing with power. But in one of the only surveys done on that question,
但我认为状态去抑制的工作非常有趣，而且可能非常有用。另一项工作是研究，比如咒骂的力量来自哪里这个问题？我们做了一些工作，收集了人们的个人咒骂历史，比如对咒骂的回忆，并试图分析这些。所以，你知道，我们可以谈论关于咒骂力量来源的“肥皂和水”假说，即作为一个孩子你咒骂，成年人因为你咒骂而训斥你，甚至可能去到用肥皂和水洗你的嘴，而且，你知道，那种创伤，那种羞耻感或任何东西，赋予了咒骂力量。但在关于该问题的唯一调查之一中，
only less than half the participants could recall any such incident from their childhood. So it suggests that that's probably a stereotype and there's other more new. nuanced ways the power of swearing comes about. So that's a research agenda. And the other one I've already mentioned is trying to find this dose response effect to understand whether there is this double taboo hypothesis. If we have an intermediate, so we have the full-on F word and a neutral word, so double taboo for the F word, if we have a single taboo, like a mild swear word perhaps,
只有不到一半的参与者能回忆起童年时期发生过此类事件。这表明这可能是一种刻板印象，关于咒骂力量的形成还有其他更微妙的方式。所以这是一个研究议程。另一个我已经提到过，就是试图找到这种剂量反应效应，以了解是否存在这种双重禁忌假设。如果我们有一个中间项，比如我们有完整的F词和一个中性词，那么F词就是双重禁忌，如果我们有一个单一禁忌，比如一个温和的脏话，
or just a taboo idea, like going to the toilet, for example, without any swear words attached to it, how would that play? So that would be interesting, theoretically interesting, to pursue as well. So those are the things on the agenda. Dr. Stevens, I want to thank you for joining me today. I'm sure I'll be thinking of you the next time I go to the gym. Give it a go. It might help. I will. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website.
或者仅仅是一个禁忌概念，比如上厕所，而不附带任何脏话，那会是什么样呢？所以从理论上讲，深入研究这一点也会很有趣。这些就是议程上的事情。史蒂文斯博士，我想感谢您今天加入我的节目。我相信下次我去健身房时一定会想起您。试一试吧。也许会有帮助。我会的。您可以在我们的网站上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinemann. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills.
网址是speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何您获取播客的地方。如果您喜欢您所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦内曼制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯。
Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
放松一下，让拉尔夫超市的配送服务为您处理本周的杂货采购。我们只从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件商品。接着我们将其全部打包，并在短短30分钟内送达，因此您可以确信这就是您订购的商品。通过拉尔夫超市的配送和自提服务，以您的方式获取新鲜杂货。现在，您的首笔配送或自提订单可节省20美元。拉尔夫超市，为每个人提供新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。